in today's society there are a variety
of options for a person to grow their
savings or to be more specific than
money a person's money can be invested
in a variety of ways these options are
either hazardous or safe
and cryptocurrency is one among them
basically it is a form of payment that
is used to exchange goods and services
and there are several type of
cryptocurrencies present in the market
and one among them which is recently
bagging a lot of popularity and interest
is stable coins
but this makes me question what is
stable coin and why people are
interested in it
so hey everyone
and i welcome to this new video of
simply learn
on stablecoin explain
in this video i'll take you through
every answer to your questions on stable
coins
so without doing any further delay let's
get started but before moving ahead
please do subscribe to our youtube
channel and do hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simplylearn
so moving on let me give you an overview
of all the topics you are going to cover
across in this video
first we will understand the basics and
explore what is stable coins
following that we will look into the
types of stable coins
after that we will have a crisp
comparison between stable coins and
other cryptocurrencies
moving on
we will have a look at some of best
stable coins according to market
capitalization
after that we will dive down deeper and
understand why is it so important
and in the end we will see what can we
do with these stable coins so now let's
get started with the basics
what is stablecoin
a stablecoin is a type of cryptocurrency
that is backed by reserve asset like the
us dollar or gold that aims to provide
price stability
it started gaining popularity since they
try to combine the best of both worlds
the rapid processing and security or
privacy of cryptocurrency payments
as well as the volatility free and
stable prices of paid currencies so
now that we know
what stablecoin is
let's explore its types
the first one that we are going to
understand is fiat collateralized stable
coins
it uses a fiat currency reserve such as
the us dollar to issue a sufficient
number of crypto dollar to other types
of collateral include precious metals
such as gold and silver as well as
commodities such as oil but the majority
of today's fair collateralized stable
coins use dollar reserves
now independent custodians manage such
results which are audited on a regular
basis to ensure that the essential
compliance is met
tether and true usd are popular
cryptocurrencies that are backed by
dollar deposits and have the same value
as a single us dollar
now moving on to the next one we have
crypto collateralized stable coins
stable coins that are crypto
collateralized are backed by other
cryptocurrencies because the reserve
cryptocurrency may be volatile such
stable coins are over collateralized
which means that a larger number of
cryptocurrency tokens are keep as a
result for releasing a smaller number of
stable coins
now coming to the last one that we have
is
non-collateralized or algorithmic
stablecoin
now this don't have any reserves but
they do have a working mechanism
to keep the price table similar to that
of a central bank the dollar
pet base coin for example employs a
consensus method to increase or reduce
token production based on demand
now such practices can be compared to a
central bank producing bank notes to
sustain fiat currency valuations
it is possible to achieve this by
developing a smart contract on a
decentralized platform that can execute
independently so now that we have a fair
knowledge of stablecoin let's have a
quick comparison between stablecoin and
other cryptocurrencies to understand
their functioning even better
so the first one is it is possible to
accurately predict fluctuations in the
value of stablecoin
on the other hand it is difficult to
anticipate the trend in the value of
other cryptocurrencies
the second one is stable coins are
centralized as they are maintained by
independent custodians
on the other hand cryptocurrencies are
decentralized
the third one we have is stablecoins
values remains constant at one dollar
cryptocurrency on the other hand has a
price range depending on its performance
in market capitalization
and the fourth one is stablecoin
price remains constant making them
non-volatile cryptocurrencies on the
other hand have a lot of insecurity
making them extremely unpredictable and
highly volatile
now let's have a look at some of the
best stable coins according to the
market capitalization
first we have is tether with the market
capitalization of 79.5 billion dollar
then we have usd coin with market
capitalization of 53.5 billion
following that we have binance usd with
market capitalization of 18.3 billion
dollar
then we have terra usd where a market
capitalization of 13 billion
then we have die with market
capitalization of 9.7 billion dollar
following that we have true usd with
market capitalization of 1.5 billion
dollar
then we have tax dollar with market
capitalization of
947.4 billion dollar
following that we have neutrino usd with
the market capitalization
of
493.9 billion dollars
now let's understand why stable coins
are so important to
people
stable coins are devoid of the volatile
nature of non-pet cryptocurrencies while
retaining some of their most valuable
properties
like
stable coins are open global and
available to everyone on the internet 24
7.
they transport data quickly cheaply and
very securely
and they are programmable and digitally
native to the internet
now that we have covered almost
everything about stable coins and its
concepts now let's see what all can we
do with these stable
coins first is cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin and ether have a lot of
volatility sometimes even by the minute
buyers and sellers can have confidence
that the value of their tokens will
neither grow nor fall
unpredictably in the near future the
asset is linked to a more stable
currency
or say stable coins the second one is
stable coins can be held without a bank
account and a simple to transfer the
value of stable coins may be easily
moved around the world even to countries
where the us dollar is difficult to come
by or where the local currency is
volatile
coming to the third one is there are
several simple ways to earn income on a
stable coin investment which is often
higher than what a bank would offer
so for the fourth one we have
with transfer fees of less than one
dollar people have sent as much as a
million dollar worth of usdc
and the fifth the last one is stable
coins like usdc is a wonderful
alternative for transporting money
around the world because of their quick
processing and cheap transaction fees so
well this was all about stable coins
i hope you enjoyed this video and
learned something new from it
if you have any questions please feel
free to ask them in the comment section
our team will reach out to you soon
thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here